Wir wollen sprechen über die 2. Bundesliga der Männer. Das sind jetzt auch schon 28 Spieltage gespielt und es wird so langsam kribbelig. Aufstieg, Abstieg, all das wollen wir heute besprechen. Mit einer tollen Runde. Thorsten Wiese ist hier vom Gebrabbel Rot-Weiß-Podcast. Susanne Vetter ist hier von der Osnabrücker Zeitung und dem Podcast Brückengeflüster. Und Thomas Haufe ist hier vom Nurder FCM-Podcast. Was für eine geile Podcastrunde. Wir starten, ich freue mich. Und nun im Programm – der Rasenfunk.
Und das an Zunno. Markus Kort aus dem Gebühl. Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Und es ging ja auch sehr erfolgreich los. Dafür, dass Uwe Koschin gesagt hat, stellt euch mal drauf ein, dass ihr irgendwie Seife für die Augen mitnehmen müsst, finde ich Tor in der dritten Minute und Tor in der 21. Minute jetzt nicht so schlecht. Und wenn man gleichzeitig weiß, dass die Defensive ja aktuell auch gut steht. Jetzt blicke ich aufs Restprogramm von Osnabrück und dann sehe ich eben, du hast es gerade schon angesprochen, jetzt ein Auswärtsspiel bei Kiel. Auch da drückt euch, also Thorsten ist heute wirklich derjenige, der allen Gästen fest dir die Daumen drückt. Es tut mir leid, dass ich nicht mit dem HSV oder Kiel spielen kann. Also das wird natürlich aber dennoch eine Aufgabe, trotz des gedrückten Daumens von Thorsten. Aber dann haben wir Heimspiel gegen Eintracht Braunschweig, die sind aktuell 6 Punkte weg. Das Auswärtsspiel Magdeburg, was wir vorhin schon angesprochen haben. Heimspiel gegen Schalke 04, die sind aktuell 8 Punkte weg. Aber wir haben schon darüber gesprochen, Schalke spielt ein bisschen wie ein Absteiger. Zumindest hängen sie da unten drin. Dann auswärts bei St. Pauli, die könnten dann schon durch sein, ist der vorletzte Spieltag und dann Heimspiel gegen Hertha BSC. Es ist natürlich von allen Teams, die da unten drin stehen, die größte Aufgabe für Osnabrück, da irgendwie noch Richtung Relegationsplatz zu hüpfen. Wenn man aber gleichzeitig sieht, dass zwischen Rang 12 und Rang 17 gerade nur 3 Punkte liegen, dann wissen wir, dass da eigentlich auch alle nervös sind. Und da hat man es ja schon häufiger erlebt, dass manche auch übereinander stäufern. Was rechnest du dem VfL noch aus?
Also, ich habe heute nochmal mit Uwe Kuschin gesprochen heute Morgen. Wir haben so ein Video- Interview immer nach dem Spieltag. Und da habe ich ihn nochmal gefragt, weil er gestern in der PK gesagt hat, die Chance nach dem Sieg gestern gegen Fürth ist jetzt um 1% auf den Klassenerhalt nochmal größer geworden als vorher. Ich habe ihn gefragt, ob er nochmal nachgerechnet hat. Hat er? Er bleibt dabei. Und ich glaube auch, dass es im Moment wichtig ist, sich nicht zu sehr darauf nochmal zu fokussieren und zu gucken. Weil, wie du schon sagst, da werden noch einige nervös werden. Da muss man jetzt einfach schauen. Gegen Kiel wird es maximal schwer, würde Daniel Tunz sagen.
Muss man die etwa niederringen?
Ja, wie gesagt, ich glaube, die Hoffnung flackert noch und das ist eigentlich auch das Wichtigste, dass man selbst, wenn es am Ende nicht reicht, weil das muss man vielleicht auch noch hinzufügen, ja, sind jetzt sechs Punkte auf dem Relegationsplatz und sieben wären es auf dem Nicht-Abschiebsplatz, aber da ist ja noch dieses unglaublich schlechte Torverhältnis dabei. Also, da muss man auch immer noch einen dazu draufrechnen. Trotzdem, solange da irgendwie noch was drin ist, wird die Mannschaft da, glaube ich, alles geben und das ist auch etwas, jeder, der schon mal Abstiegskampf mitgemacht hat, der weiß, dass es irgendwann so einen Punkt gibt, da kippt es oft und da fängt es dann in der Mannschaft auch an, dass jeder mit dem Finger auf dem anderen zeigt und das ist halt beim VfL nicht passiert und vor allem nicht passiert nach dem 0-4 gegen Düsseldorf, wo man so etwas vielleicht auch hätte erwarten können, dass so ein Klackdruck eintritt. Und im Gegenteil, man ist zurückgekommen aus dieser Länderspielpause und hat sich jetzt wieder so präsentiert. Also die haben gezeigt, dass sie kämpfen können. Die wissen seit letztem Jahr, 90 plus 6, ist es nicht aus, bevor es nicht aus ist. Und ja, deswegen, ich glaube jetzt eigentlich die Rechenspiele und wer wie was und ob St. Pauli dann schon durch ist oder wie es da aussieht, da braucht man gar nicht anfangen. Ich glaube, die werden bis zum Schluss alles geben und selbst, wenn es am Ende nicht reicht, wird man in Osnabrück jetzt nach dieser Rückrunde auch sehen, dass diese Mannschaft eben sich dagegen gestemmt hat und alles gegeben hat und auch so was dann anerkennen.
Ich finde es ganz interessant zu sehen. Es gibt so verschiedene Gruppen an Vereinen unten im Abstiegskampf. Es gibt Teams wie Osnabrück und Braunschweig, die so von vornherein eigentlich reingegangen sind und gesagt haben, ja, das wird schwer. Und so war dann auch die Hinrunde. Dann gibt es die Aufsteiger, bei denen es euphorisch ganz gut lief – Elversberg, Wien, Wiesbaden – die jetzt hinten raus, wie es häufig bei Aufsteigern ist, aber so langsam die Abstiegsplätze wieder näher kommen sehen und so ein bisschen gerade nicht schaffen, den Schalter umzulegen. Und dann hast du die Vereine, die ganz andere Ideen hatten, wie Lautern oder Schalke, die auch vielleicht eine andere Qualität haben, die es aber einfach nicht schaffen, da unten rauszukommen. Ich weiß noch nicht, wo ich Magdeburg hinpacke, das muss Thomas mir sagen, aber ich finde das ganz interessant zu sehen. Ich mache gerade Schubladen auf, aber habe ich wen vergessen da unten? Die sehe ich dann auch in der Gruppe, Osnabrück, Braunschweig, die wussten, glaube ich, auch von Anfang an, das wird schwer dieses Jahr.
Ja, also ich glaube, hier war auch, also ich kenne hier wenig Leute, die in meinem Umfeld, die vor der Saison auch gesagt haben, es kann für den FC Magdeburg nur um den Klassenerhalt gehen, alles andere ist vermessen. Und auch wenn wir einen guten Saisonstart hatten, also für mich war das immer alles Bonus, das waren mal alles Punkte, wo ich gesagt habe, jeder Punkt, den wir da geholt haben, ist gut im Abstiegskampf, mehr nicht. Und ja, hat sich ja leider Gottes auch bestätigt, dass es dann doch brutaler Abstiegskampf am Ende noch wird für uns. Mal gucken, wie das dann am Ende ausgeht.
Ja, und da ist eben wirklich Resilienz ein wichtiges Thema. Und das muss ich schon auch sagen. Also, wenn ich jetzt überlege, wann hatte ich eigentlich bei Osnabrück, also wann hatte ich die abgeschrieben, dann war das für mich ehrlicherweise, als man nach 2 zu 1 Führung auf dem Betzenberg noch in der 92 Minuten mit 2 zu 3 verliert. Da dachte ich mir, okay, gut, wenn dir sowas passiert, dann hilft auch dieses kurze Ausbaubäume nicht. Aber jetzt sehen wir ja, naja, wer weiß, vielleicht geht da noch was. Wollen wir vielleicht zum Abschluss ein Power-Ranking machen, dieser Teams, die da unten drinnen stehen? Das ist natürlich höchst subjektiv und so weiter, aber das würde mich mal interessieren. Ich würde vorschlagen, wir machen den Cut bei Magdeburg, denn Elversberg 36 Punkte, es sind zwar nur 6 Punkte zu Braunschweig, aber da müssen ja so viele Teams sich dran vorbeischieben. Elversberg, ihr seid durch, vielleicht habe ich jetzt gejinkst, bitte schreibt mir keine E-Mails, sollte es so sein. Aber Magdeburg, Schalke, Wiesbaden, Rostock, Braunschweig, Lautern und Osnabrück. Thomas, du darfst anfangen. Wen davon würdest du aktuell am stärksten sehen?
Am stärksten von denen? Tatsächlich Braunschweig.
Thorsten nickt, aber Susanne ist irritiert.
Ich habe einen schlechten Eindruck von Osnabrück natürlich aus dem direkten Duell, aber Braunschweig fand ich jetzt schon stärker.
Ich hoffe, dass nach dem 20.04. das nach Osnabrück schwenkt.
Okay, ihr habt das direkte Duell. Das wird wirklich sehr, sehr interessant.
Ich glaube, dass das wäre. Ich glaube, also Braunschweig ist ja, aber das ist 20.04.
Okay, aber das heißt, du hast damit indirekt gesagt, Susanne, selbst wenn wir jetzt mal Braunschweig in unserem Power-Ranking auf einsetzen, dann wäre Osnabrück für dich die 2 aktuell.
Bei Schalke konntest du immer drauf achten, ob sie auswärts oder zu Hause spielen. Das ist einfach so.
Aber würdet ihr dann Schalke – also ist natürlich zu Hause besser für alle diejenigen, die sich das gefragt haben – Heimtabelle Rang 7, Auswärtstabelle Rang 18? Das ist wirklich verrückt. Ich wusste, dass Heim gut war, aber ich wusste nicht, wie schlecht auswärts war. Aber wo würdet ihr Schalke hinpacken? Ich meine, wir müssen jetzt kein genaues Ranking machen. Aber Braunschweig gerade eine gute Phase, Osnabrück eine gute Phase. Wo wir die genau hinpacken, ist dann letztlich egal. Aber was machen wir dann Thomas mit Schalke 04?
Also ich habe letzte Saison, als ja Bielefeld in einer ähnlichen Situation war, habe ich eigentlich, bis sie dann abgestiegen sind, eigentlich immer gesagt, bei denen, die haben zu viel Qualität, die bleiben drin. Das Gleiche habe ich von Schalke auch gesagt. Jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob das ein schlechtes Oben für Schalke ist, weil ich das bei Bielefeld auch getan habe. Also es ist schon brutal, wenn man sieht, dass eine Mannschaft, die ja eigentlich qualitativ schon eigentlich mindestens ins Mittelfeld der 2. Liga gehört, dass die so gar nicht auf die Beine kommen. Und das ist tatsächlich – ich kenne jetzt das Schlussprogramm von Schalke, ich weiß nicht, wen die jetzt noch alles haben – aber ich denke, am Ende wird Schalke – ich denke, am Ende wird Schalke mit zwei blauen Augen davon kommen und auf Platz 14 oder 13 die Klasse haben.
Ja, das glaube ich auch. Die haben sich zuletzt zumindest in den Heimspielen doch sehr stabil präsentiert. Das ist auch so meine Sorge, weil wir eben noch Ende des Monats dahin müssen auf Schalke. Dann haben wir noch mal am Samstagabend auch so ein Flutlichtspiel und so. Das ist so die Atmosphäre, die will man da vielleicht dann nicht haben für die Heimmannschaft. Das ist so mit das Spiel, von dem ich den meisten Respekt habe. Da bin ich mir nicht sicher, ob wir da gewinnen werden. Und ansonsten glaube ich eben, dass die Heimspiele reichen. Diese Heimstärke ist jetzt vielleicht übertrieben, aber die Stabilität zu Hause, glaube ich, reicht für Schalke zusammen mit dem Kader für den Klassenerhalt.
Die nächsten zwei Spiele könnten da schon ganz wichtig werden. Heimspiel gegen Nürnberg, gegen die sieht man traditionell eigentlich immer ganz gut aus. Und dann bei Elversberg auswärts. Und Schalke braucht ja nicht mehr viele Punkte. Aber gut, wir haben schon andere Dinge erlebt. Was machen wir? Ja, wäre dann schon Rostock der Nächste im Power-Ranking. Müsste eigentlich fast sein, wenn man so nach aktueller Form geht. Haben natürlich auch noch einige Brocken vor sich. Also spielen Harter, Magdeburg, St. Pauli, KSC, Schalke, Paderborn. Also haben so eigentlich mit wehen Wiesbaden die stärksten Gegner jetzt noch als Nächste. Susanne, wie schaust du auf Rostock?
Ja, also ich glaube auch, die haben jetzt wirklich zuletzt eine ganz gute Serie hingelegt. Wenn ich das richtig erinnere, glaube ich nur Kiel verloren, oder? Aber dann, ja, sich wirklich ordentlich und gut präsentiert. Aber das Restprogramm, das ist schon happig. Also da ist, da kommt einiges auf Rostock zu und, ja, schwierig.
Und ähnlich ist es ehrlicherweise mit Wien – Wiesbaden. Düsseldorf natürlich, wissen wir ja, in der Wunde im Schmuckkästchen. Thorsten freut sich schon. Dann Lautern, Fürth, Kiel, Braunschweig, St. Pauli. St. Pauli immerhin am letzten Spieltag mit Lautern und Braunschweig auch noch zwei direkte Duelle, aber beide auswärts für Wien – Wiesbaden. Du hast ja, Thorsten, fast schon so ein bisschen angekündigt, die Aufsteiger, die rutschen ja manchmal hinten raus noch rein. Wenn ich mir das jetzt so angucke, könnte ich mir das ehrlich gesagt auch vorstellen.
Das ist meine These, dass Wien-Wiesbaden am Ende noch unten rein rutscht, vielleicht auf den Relegationsplatz oder sogar tiefer. Schlechtes Test, Rückrundenteam. Und also ich habe ein bisschen das Spiel jetzt in Rostock gesehen und so. Das läuft schon lange nicht mehr so rund wie es dann phasenweise in der Hinrunde, als sie uns auch geschlagen haben nach einer harten Pokalpartie in Unterhaching. Da mussten wir zwei Tage später, freitags abends zu Hause ran und haben 1-3 wirklich sehr kraftlos gegen Wien-Wiesbaden verloren. Die Form haben sie, was ich zuletzt gesehen habe, überhaupt nicht mehr. Und das meinte ich eben mit so den berühmten Schalter immer umlegen. Ob sie das noch mal schaffen, da bin ich mir gerade nicht sicher. Ich bin schon sehr zuversichtlich, was das Spiel nächste Woche allen Spaß beiseite betrifft, da wir sehr stabil im Moment sind. Ich sehe gerade wirklich keinen Grund, warum das in Wien-Wiesbaden nächste Woche schiefgehen sollte. Das ist dann eine weitere Niederlage. Sie haben jetzt eine ganze Reihe Niederlagen zuletzt gesammelt. Vor allem dieses Heimspiel gegen Osnabrück dürfte ihnen wehgetan haben. Dann haben sie vorher einmal unentschieden gegen Hannover zu Hause gespielt, aber dann auch gegen Paderborn verloren. Die Heimspiele liefen zuletzt gar nicht gut bei Wien-Wiesbaden. Es sind ja keine ballbesitzorientierte Mannschaft, die auch aus einer sehr kompakten Defensive kommt, was man natürlich auswärts eigentlich gut nutzen kann. Aber wir haben heute schon häufiger darüber gesprochen, dass die Gegner sich dann phasenweise eingestellt haben. Ich glaube, das ist bei Wien-Wiesbaden mittlerweile eben auch der Fall, dass man weiß, den läuft man nicht mehr ins offene Messer. Da muss man auch ein bisschen die Qualitätsfrage stellen, wenn man sich den Kader anguckt. Da ist nicht so viel Zweitliga-Erfahrung dabei und das ist ja auch nicht – also das kennt man auch aus der ersten Liga, dass in diesen letzten Spieltagen auch gerade so die Mannschaften, die sowas schon öfters mal mitgemacht haben, dass die sich da häufig stabiler präsentieren als Teams, für die es eigentlich rosarot lief die ganze Saison und die am Ende dann auf einmal noch ums Überleben kämpfen müssen. Also Wien-Wiesbaden ist für mich ein heißer Kandidat von den Teams, die noch unten reinrutschen, von denen man es vor ein paar Wochen vielleicht noch gar nicht gedacht hätte.
Das sind hervorragende Nachrichten für Lautern und Magdeburg. Das sind die 17 Teams, die wir jetzt noch nicht gerankt haben. Lautern in der Rückrundetabelle, 16. Magdeburg, 15. Thomas, ich komme nicht drüber hinweg, wie frustriert du vorhin warst, und gleichzeitig habe ich Hände ringend nach irgendwelchen Argumenten gesucht und habe keine gefunden. Nicht im Kader, nicht auf der Trainerposition, umfällt noch am ehesten. Also Magdeburg kann ja auch eine Wucht entwickeln. Anders gelagert als Osnabrück, aber ja auch durchaus ähnlich, also dass man ja eigentlich lange hinter der Mannschaft steht und auch heimstark ist mit einem besonderen Stadion und so weiter. Müssen wir trotzdem Magdeburg und Lautern hier so ans Ende dieser Liste packen. Heißt ja nicht, dass man dann auch absteigt, weil vielleicht…
Zurzeit bei fünf Spielen, zwei Punkten, 0 zu 11 Toren, kommt man da glaube ich nicht drum rum. Also zurzeit kann man das glaube ich, ohne da jetzt böse sein zu wollen, kann man das glaube ich so sehen. Also diese fünf Spiele, dieser Trend spricht jetzt nicht gerade für uns. Ich glaube nur Elbersberg war in dem Zeitraum schlechter und ging die Spielzeit auch nur 0-0 dann. Ich denke, ich habe nur mal den Spaß gemacht und habe heute Nachmittag mal auf Kicker.de diesen Tabellenrechner mal genutzt. Genau. Susanne tut mir leid, aber tatsächlich ist für mich dann Osnabrück dieses Schlüsselspiel gewesen. Also ich bin am Ende bei 37 Punkten rausgekommen mit einem Sieg gegen Osnabrück und der war nachher entscheidend, dass man dann am Ende die Klasse hält. Ich glaube tatsächlich, das wird für uns auch dann das Schlüsselheimspiel um diese Saison dann noch zu retten und deswegen hoffe ich einfach mal, dass Osnabrück bis dahin vielleicht aus eigener Sicht natürlich vielleicht keine Chancen mehr hat noch drin zu bleiben, dass man da eben so ein bisschen so eine Egalstimmung reinkommt. Also nicht, dass man da nicht mehr spielen will, sondern dass man eben sagt, okay, hat er keine positiven Auswirkungen mehr. Ansonsten, es gibt mir tatsächlich nur Hoffnung, diese drei Spiele, die wir noch haben, gegen direkte Konkurrenz. Ansonsten sieht es da bei mir zurzeit auch eher mauer aus, muss ich ganz ehrlich zugeben.
Und dann haben wir Lautern und Lautern kann Friedhelm Funkel absteigen. Ich war ja kein Fan der Verpflichtung, aber ich bin auch weit weg von der 2.
Liga.
Ich bin noch weiter weg von Kaisers Lautern, deswegen ist da meine Meinung wirklich unerheblich.
Ich habe vor drei Wochen mit Sebastian Zobel gesprochen aus der letzten Rasenfunk-Sendung ja auch hier. Er sagte mir da, dass ganz Lautern das wirklich total begrüßt. Dass das mit Gramozis wohl überhaupt nicht funktioniert hat. Ich meine, es ist ja wirklich schon der dritte Trainer diese Saison. Es war fast wie eine Erleichterung, dass dieser Wechsel noch mal stattgefunden hat. Das Feedback von ihm war, dass das sehr positiv gesehen wird. Mal Pokal beiseite. Haben sie ja auch bis auf die zwei Niederlagen zuletzt gegen den HSV und uns eigentlich auch deutlich stabiler agiert. Das HSV-Spiel war für mich so ein typisches Abstiegskandidatenspiel. Du bist nicht die schlechtere Mannschaft, aber du machst deine Dinge nicht. Irgendwann wird aus vielen Schulterklopfen – na ja, ihr wart ja ganz gut – heute war er wirklich nicht gut. Wenn ein Trainer das wirklich verhindern kann, wenn einer weiß, was dazu zu sagen ist und wie eine Mannschaft einzustellen ist, dann ist das Friedhelm Funkel. Bei allem, was man über ihn sagen kann. Das kann er und meistens hat er auch das richtige Gespür dafür. Das ist der Funkelbonus. Den würde ich tatsächlich Lautern am Ende geben und selbst wenn es die Relegation sein muss.
Also ich sehe es ähnlich. Ich finde auch, Lautern hat mit der Funkelverpflichtung vieles richtig gemacht. Wenn man mal auf die letzten Spiele guckt, muss man die Kölner auch ein bisschen dorfen lassen. Die haben in Rostock 3-0 gewonnen, die haben gegen Osnabrück 3-2 gewonnen, dann haben sie in Hannover 1-1 gespielt und jetzt haben sie gegen Düsseldorf und Hamburg, gegen zwei Aufstiegsaspiranten. Du hast es schon gesagt, gegen Düsseldorf, das war ja kein 1-3, finde ich am Ende. Das war ja vom Spielverlauf eigentlich maximal ein 1-2. Also das ist eine Höhe. War das dann auch mindestens ein Tor zu viel? Düsseldorf hat dann einfach brutale Qualität und das hat man eben gesehen. Und jetzt gegen Hamburg eigentlich genau das Gleiche. Und wenn man dann mal guckt auf das Restprogramm von Lautern, die haben zu Hause Wiesbaden, die haben zu Hause uns und die haben zu Hause Braunschweig. Und wer schon in Kaiserslautern war, der weiß, was dieses Stadion für eine Wucht entwickeln kann, wenn es da mal rund geht. Und ich glaube schon, dass die in diesen drei Spielen, ich hoffe natürlich nicht gegen uns, aber in den anderen beiden Spielen, gegen Wiesbaden und Braunschweig, ihre Punkte holen werden. Und deswegen denke ich auch, es wird am Ende Wiesbaden erwischen als 17. Und dann Relegation ist mir egal, so lange wir das nicht sind.
Und das ist doch ein Schlusswort und wir haben sogar maximal nochmal untergebracht. Das schmeckt mir ganz wunderbar. Wir werden es ja eh verfolgen und uns angucken, in aller Ruhe oder auch Emotionen, je nachdem, welchem Fanlager man da angehört. Ihr 4, ich, äh, nee, ihr 3, seht ihr, ich kann nicht mal mehr zählen. Es waren zu viele Sendungen zuletzt. Ist dieser vierte Gast gerade hier anwesend? Nein, nur in meinem Kopf. Es ist wie Temfunkel. Also, ihr 3, ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich, dass ihr euch die Zeit genommen habt. Alle Verzögerungen, die wir jetzt hatten, zum Trotz. Ganz, ganz herzlichen Dank an Thomas Haufe vom Nurder FCM Podcast. Danke dir. Sehr gerne. Und danke an Jorsten Wiese von Gebrabbel Rot-Weiß. Danke, dass du wieder da warst. Und herzlichen Dank an Susanne Vetter unter anderem vom Brückengeflister. Danke dir, liebe Susanne. Ja, ihr wart auch das perfekte Beispiel dafür, warum es so schön ist, mit Podcast-Expertinnen und Experten zusammen zu spielen. Wie flüssig das war. Zwischendurch hätte ich rausgehen können. Da habt ihr das hier komplett alleine übernommen. Fand ich sehr, sehr gut. Lieben Dank auch euch, lieben Hörern und Hörern, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bitte unterstützt den Rasenfunk auf rasenfunk.de slash supporters club. Erfahrt ihr, wie das geht? Auf kiosk.rasenfunk.de könnt ihr noch Tassen und so weiter erwerben. Es sind die letzten ihrer Art. 30 Prozent Rabatt gibt's da drauf. Holt sie euch, bleibt gesund und bleibt uns gewogen. Bis bald hier im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut. Das war der Rasenfunk. Bei anderen sprießen die Gehälter, bei uns nur der Rasen.